only three percent of the world's
population now live in a country where
birth rates are not declining so
declining benefits are the norm
and they started declining as I said
first in Britain but it's basically
happened everywhere it seems to just be
an inevitable consequence of
modernity that people people have for
your children and there are a whole
bunch of reasons associated with this
the one that you'll hear most commonly
shrim
um London Millennials is that it's
considered with house prices and that
here it is a factor it is that has
become more expensive particularly in
big Urban centers like London New York
San Francisco Tokyo wherever to
own property and raise children that's
not the only Factor though because if
that were the only Factor then you
wouldn't be seeing this extraordinarily
Global phenomenon of falling fertility
absolutely everywhere regardless of
house prices it does seem to be just
something about modernity discourages
family formation